was ist eigentlich schwarm intelligenz
[Musik]
natur ist chaos aber wenn man lange
genug hinschaut dann kann man muster
erkennen dieser sardinen schwarm wird
gerade von delfinen umzingelt und
angegriffen und als wäre das noch nicht
genug haben pelikane mitbekommen was
unter der wasseroberfläche abgeht und
kommen auch noch von oben ins wasser
geschossen gar keine schöne situation
für die fische als abwehrreaktion formen
sie einen dichten schwarm der die
angreifer verwirren soll durch die enge
formationen und die schnellen bewegungen
fällt es den raubtieren schwerer
einzelne fische aus dem schwarm
anzupeilen
die delfine probieren das natürlich
trotzdem ist ja all you can eat hier
aber obwohl die fische ständig
angegriffen und auseinandergetrieben
werden
finden sie denn noch immer wieder
zusammen wie geht das alleine hätten die
fische keine chance wenn zum beispiel
ein fisch in so einer situation von den
anderen getrennt wird wird er ganz
schnell umzingelt und gefressen
der natürliche instinkt eines fisches
ist es also möglichst nah an seinen
nachbarn zu bleiben und sich selber
möglichst weit von den angreifern zu
entfernen das ergebnis dieser instinkte
ist eine kugel der geometrische körper
mit der kleinstmöglichen oberfläche
wenn nun die wenigen fischer am rand der
gruppe einen angreifer sehen und die
bewegungsrichtung ändern dann führt
diese richtungsänderung der wenigen
fische dazu dass der gesamte schwarm
seine richtung ändert wenn teile eines
systems zusammen neue eigenschaften
erringen die sie alleine nicht haben
dann spricht man von mr games die
einzelnen fische reagieren hier
gemeinsam als ganzes sie agieren schon
fast wie ein einziges lebewesen das
system erkennt essverhalten oder auch
schwarm intelligenz und fische sind
nicht die einzigen tiere die das tun
können
termiten bauen riesige termitenhügel
vögel können ähnlich wie fische
angreifer im schwarm besser abwehren und
sogar zum absturz bringen und ameisen
bauen brücken mit nichts anderem als
sich selber und das alles ohne dass
jemand kommandos gibt wie krass dass
wenn das team um den wissenschaftler im
seehof er rannte veröffentlichte im
august 2015 eine wissenschaftliche
arbeit in der sie erklären wie sie
digitalen maschinen beigebracht haben so
zu denken wie ameisen in einer
computersimulation haben roboter die
aufgabe bekommen blätter von oben nach
unten zu transportieren
die roboter sind hier sehr einfach
programmiert können aber durch eine
simulierte evolution gesammelte
erfahrungen an die nächste generation
weitergeben
während die ersten simulationen noch
wenig vielversprechend aussah wurden die
roboter mit jeder generation besser bald
schon entwickelte sich ein schema
nachdem jeder roboter nicht nur für sich
alleine die blätter trägt sondern immer
eine bestimmte aufgabe übernimmt
die roboter haben sich spezialisiert und
erstaunlicherweise wird dieses system
auch von ameisen benutzt bei der blood
ernte ist eine ameise entweder ein
schneider oben im baum oder ein träger
die ameisen spezialisieren sich und auch
generell lässt sich mit dem system der
simulierten evolution unglaublich viel
über die natur lernen in dieser
simulation sieht man zum beispiel wie
ein strauß das laufen lernt ohne dass in
der simulation jemals programmiert wurde
wie der strauss laufen soll
er lernt es einfach durch trial 'never
über hunderte und tausende von
generation fällt er immer und immer und
immer wieder hin bis er irgendwann
versteht wieder aufrecht bleiben kann
was man daraus lernen kann zum beispiel
wie verschiedene tiere auf dem mond dem
mars oder dem jupiter laufen würden 11
mit aber zurück zu den schwärmen kann
man diese faszinierenden eigenschaften
auch in unserer heutigen modernen welt
anwenden
das ist ein kilo bot ein kleiner und
günstiger roboter der sich mit hilfe von
vibrationen fortbewegt und weil viel zu
günstig sind können sie auch im
allgemeinen nur drei dinge auf licht
reagieren distanzen messen und andere
kilowatt in der nähe wahrnehmen denn
davon gibt es eine menge
die keynotes werden in harvard zur
untersuchung von schwarmverhalten
benutzt sowie tier schwer entfalten die
kilos gäste in der masse ihr wahres
potenzial
so können sie zum beispiel formen
nachbilden obwohl alle kinos gleich
programmiert sind und sie keine exakten
anweisungen bekommen haben wie sie diese
aufgabe überhaupt bewältigen sollen kilo
bots helfen uns dabei zu verstehen wie
die verschiedensten tierarten
funktionieren wie zum beispiel
glühwürmchen es hinbekommen
synchronisiert zu blinken oder wie
bakterien nahrung finden wie in der
tierwelt befolgen die keynotes oft nur
drei oder vier sehr simple regeln
schaffen aber als gruppe etwas größeres
aus dem chaos entsteht ordnung das
prinzip des sparens lässt sich sogar auf
drohnen anwenden
ein kleiner trupp von drohnen kann
autonom und dezentralisiert also ohne
anführer ein gebiet erkunden
hiermit könnte man katastrophengebiete
ohne funksignal auskundschaften lassen
natürlich ist an dieser technologie wie
so oft das militär interessiert also
sind bald nicht mehr killer drohnen
sondern killer drohnen schwärme
die dann autonom auf mission gehen
können grange in zürich haben
wissenschaftler übrigens gerade nur mit
drohnen eine brücke gebaut auf der
menschen laufen können es war mussten
diese drohnen noch speziell für diese
aufgabe programmiert werden aber auch
hier kann man sich vorstellen was ein
ganzer schwarm von drohnen alles
schaffen kann mit hilfe von technologie
können wir also das schwarmverhalten von
tiere nachahmen aber könnten auch wir
menschen einen schwarm bilden nicht auf
drohnen und robotern sondern aus uns
selbst zumindest unser gehirn
funktioniert eigentlich schon genau so
ein einzelnes neuron in unserem kopf ist
wien er es ist dumm erst im
zusammenspiel mit milliarden anderer
neuronen im gehirn und deren
verbindungen können reize und
sinneseindrücke interpretiert werden
erst durch die masse entsteht ein
bewusstsein
nun ist ein projekt das die
schwarmintelligenz von menschen
aufzeigen soll
auf der plattform können mitglieder alle
möglichen fragen stellen die dann von
der community beantwortet werden wo auch
immer die lupe landet das ist die
antwort der gruppe das unglaubliche es
funktioniert die voraussagen einer
gruppe sind beinahe immer besser als die
der einzelnen mitglieder und oft sogar
besser als die der experten aus der
gruppe
dabei ist besonders die größe der
community wichtig studien haben
herausgefunden dass hier
unterschiedlicher die erfahrungen der
einzelnen mitglieder sind desto besser
die eigentliche intelligenz der
mitglieder spielt hingegen nur eine
kleine rolle und das prinzip kann man
auch auf die arbeit anwenden
ein raum voller leute ist eine
kollektive intelligenz anstatt immer
wieder die gleichen leute in einem
meeting zu packen sollte man eher viele
unterschiedliche persönlichkeiten und
berufsgruppen einladen und jeden zu wort
kommen lassen
hey je nachdem wie man fragt ist sogar
wikipedia eine kollektive intelligenz
denkt mal darüber nach die
unterschiedlichsten menschen kommen
zusammen um die gruppe also alle
menschen mit einem internetanschluss mit
informationen zu versorgen und jeder
spielt seine stärken aus indem er die
artikel schreibt über die ihr am meisten
weiß pixar projekte werden nur gefahndet
wenn eine große anzahl von menschen von
der idee überzeugt ist wenn die gruppe
also der schwarm die idee schlecht
findet wird ziemlich umgesetzt schwarm
intelligenz und wisst ihr was die
wahrscheinlich größte kollektive
intelligenz zwischen allen menschen ist
das internet selber wo sonst kommen so
viele und so unterschiedliche menschen
zusammen um gegenseitig informationen
aus
und ich möchte jetzt mal eure
intelligenz also gruppe testen und bin
schon gespannt was dabei rauskommt also
irgendwie spielregeln ich möchte dass
jeder von euch unten in die kommentare
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 100 postet aber
noch nicht drauflos tippen dass noch
nicht alles überlegt euch genau was die
anderen zuschauer im durchschnitt
antworten werden und davon müsst ihr
dann ein drittel abziehen
in einer woche wenn ich dann alle
antworten zusammenzählen und den
durchschnitt errechnet davon ziehe ich
ein drittel ab und das ist das ergebnis
und die leute die das richtige ergebnis
vorhergesagt haben die werde ich dann
nächste woche im video erwerben also
nochmal falls das so schnell wahr
überlegt euch was die anderen zuschauer
chippen werden und nehmen davon zwei
drittel
wenn ihr also denkt dass die masse im
durchschnitt 50 sagt dann nehmt ihr
davon zwei drittel bzw zieht ein drittel
ab was auch immer das ist abgerundet 33
und das schreibt ionen in die kommentare
denkt genau darüber nach denkt drüber
nach was die anderen gerade nachdenken
werden
ich bin gespannt was dabei rauskommt
wenn ihr das ergebnis schon etwas früher
hören wollt dann folgt mir auf twitter
oder leicht meine seite auf facebook das
solltet ihr sowieso tun weil ich da
immer spannende videos bilder und links
posten zu allen themen über die ich hier
sowieso schon videos machen
also werde er nicht bereuen da gibt es
auf jeden fall immer interessante dinge
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lasst einen daumen nach oben da und
schaut euch mal letzten videos an wenn
ihr die noch nicht gesehen habe
ansonsten viel spaß
bis nächste woche
[Musik]